Let's talk about what happens on the
inside of your body when you're fasting
so over here we have a start of a fast
and we go 24 hours 48 and 72 so there's
a lot of really magical things that
happen when you fast our bodies have
developed over a long period of time and
have adapted to starvation many many
times so we have all these unique
proteins that get expressed or turned on
that have to do with your brain doing
better the different parts of your body
is surviving better our bodies have not
adapted to the frequency of eating like
we do now like every three hours so
right around 12 hours we get this spike
in growth hormone growth hormone is the
anti-aging hormone it's the main fat
burning hormone it's the hormone
involved with healing joints and it's
involved with protein synthesis or
making different new proteins some
people take growth hormone to get
injected I don't recommend it but they
take it to help heal certain parts of
your body but guess what
fasting will trigger it automatically so
just by the fact that you're fasting you
can increase growth hormone and of
course exercise will also increase
growth hormone as well so it starts
about 12 hours and it increases as you
go on and on now at about 18 hours you
start developing something called autophagy
autophagy is an interesting thing that
happens with your body where you start
recycling old damaged proteins and
microbes as well one type of protein
would be the advanced glycated end
products which basically when you
combined glucose with a protein it
becomes very sticky so let's say you're
on a high carbohydrate diet and that
sugar combines with your own protein in
your body and that starts to glide Kate
or just kind of destroy some of the
proteins in your body and then they
don't function anymore and they get
sticky and they clog things up well
guess what your body will start cleaning
all that up and turning these damaged
proteins into new amino acids where your
body can use them
amyloid plaquing which occurs in the
brain and other parts of the body is a
type of protein that can be cleaned up
with a toffee gene so it's any type of
cellular proteins that are not working
anymore in your body
autophagy will start cleaning that up and
start to renew the tissue and it starts
right about 18 hours and it gets more
and more and more as you start fasting
in about 24 hours and a little bit
longer you start to really deplete this
glycogen Reserve this storage supply of
glucose in your liver so the more that
the liver is depleted with glycogen the
more you're going to be running on
ketones as the alternative fuel and if
you have a fatty liver for example your
body will start using that fat and
turning that into ketones so your body
is finally able to start tapping into
this stored energy and you're running
more and more on ketones which is a
superior fuel and because you're running
on ketones ketones are an appetite
suppressant so your hunger goes away
cravings are gone there are antioxidants
so you're building up your antioxidant
reserve they provide more oxygen so your
body is running out more oxygen less co2
then it's more efficient and because
ketones are a much more efficient fuel
than glucose the thyroid does not have
to work as hard and you may find that
your t3 is a little bit lower but the
thyroid stimulating hormone is normal
and all that means is your thyroid is
adapting to this new type of fuel now
some other cool things that are
happening right around 24 hours
is that your inflammation is dropping
significantly if you wanted to even
speed it up more you can add some
vitamin D to that and that will really
help you so any type of conditions that
involve inflammatory states like
arthritis bursitis autoimmune type
conditions start to improve about 24
hours you start getting more gut healing
because the gut now doesn't have to work
so frequently with the gallbladder being
stimulated and the pancreas stimulating
its enzymes the gut finally has a chance
to just chill out so if you have this
condition called SIBO which there are
microbes in the small and
testin and they should normally be in
the large intestine that starts to
become corrective you start increasing
stem cell in the gut so your gut starts
to heal the heart loves ketones way
better than glucose so you start getting
improvement in the cardiovascular
function and as well as the brain
function there's something called BDNF
this is a factor that helps make new
brain cells so your brain starts to
repair at 24 hours as you keep going on
you would think you're going to be
losing muscle protein but that's not
really what happens because your body
becomes more efficient and there are
certain genes that are sparing proteins
so it's not using muscle protein so the
efficiency of fuel is much better plus
with autophagy you're using the old
damaged proteins and giving you new
protein so the combination is really
good so the amount of nutrition that you
really need to run the body is a lot
less because the body just dows down and
it can run on less amount of nutrients
so that's a positive thing now the other
thing that happens during autophagy is
that you're also cleaning out microbes
and fungus and mold and yeast and to
kill off those microbes your body
develops certain oxidants and you also
have antioxidants on the flipside so
your body actually makes things like
hydrogen peroxide to kill off microbes
but it also in the left side makes its
own antioxidants to actually protect the
body against the oxidation so we have
this entire balance it's only when we
have lower amounts of antioxidants and
higher amount of accidents that we get
this thing called oxidative stress which
things start breaking down but when
you're doing fasting you're getting a
nice balance of more antioxidants and
your body is starting to heal now when
you get to 48 hours you really start to
stimulate the stem cells these are
undifferentiated cells in other words
they're cells that don't have a purpose
so they can turn into this tissue or
that tissue depending on what the body
needs so you start to stimulate the stem
cell and get more
healing and more repair more anti-aging
you also get decrease risks of certain
types of cancer you get shrinkage of
certain tumors you start making more
mitochondria now if you push it and go
up to 72 hours you get even more
stimulation of stem cells okay in better
immune function but when you actually
get into 72 hours or greater I recommend
you do that as a periodic thing simply
because a lot of people going into this
have nutritional deficiencies in there
if you jump in too fast you can get a
little bit dizzy you can have some side
effects so you want to gradually do this
over a period of time but those are some
general things that happen when you're
fasting I recommend doing intermittent
fasting on a regular basis okay and
probably a good average pattern of doing
this would be doing 18 hours of fasting
with a six-hour window so you would eat
and then wait to six hours later and
then eat and then fast for 18 hours this
would be a really good pattern to follow
and then you can actually make it more
strict over time depending on how you do
then what you can do is periodic prolong
fasting to achieve additional health
benefits whether it's for your immune
system because you have an autoimmune
problem or you just want to look younger
with your skin or you want more brain
cells you want a better heart function
better gut function or let's say you
have cancer and you want to improve that
because one thing that fasting will do
is it will increase your resistance to
stress and even if someone's on
chemotherapy it will actually help the
body's resistance against chemicals and
poisons which is quite remarkable make
sure you take your minerals during
fasting so I know a lot of people
recommend just doing either water fast
you're just drinking water or a dry fast
where you're not drinking anything I
recommend doing a water fast with
nutrients just because if you are
deficient
you can have problems so you want you
minerals you want your B vitamins and
you want your salt very important right
around 8 o'clock in the morning you have
the spike in cortisol and if cortisol
spikes sometimes that can cause your
body to make more glucose and you can
have higher blood sugars and it happens
with a lot of people with blood sugar
issues nothing to worry about that will
improve over time but if you just add
exercise in the morning that will burn
off some of that extra sugar and if
you're fasting it's not coming from your
diet it's just coming from your liver
making glucose making a little too much
because maybe the cortisol is too high
okay so just wanted to point it out and
I have videos on that I put a link down
below it's called a dawn phenomena now
if your LDL so called bad cholesterol
which is not really bad low density
lipoprotein is increased the reason for
this especially if you're not consuming
or any type of significant carbohydrates
and you're doing fasting this is
increased from a different reason think
about one of the purposes of LDL it's to
deliver cholesterol to different tissues
right well think about all the things
that are happening when your body is
fasting you are going through a major
healing process and cholesterol is the
raw material for your cell membranes for
your brain to make hormones to make
vitamin D to make bile 40% of all the
cholesterol in your body is there to
supply the membrane of your cells which
is essential to protect the cell and
allow for things to go in and out of the
cell so maybe one of the reasons why
your body might need the cholesterol to
be transported through this carrier
protein is healing the cellular
membranes or it could be that it needs
to have the raw material to make more
hormones I would not worry about that if
you are concerned there are various
tests that you could do to determine
what's happening to this cholesterol
isn't doing damage or not but I would
not worry about it but anyway I wanted
to create a video just to kind of show
you what happens
to the inside of your body when you're
fasting thanks for watching so if you
want more knowledge on how to create a
healthy body subscribe now and get daily
notifications